hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about cavity susceptibility particularly
as it's caused by oral bacteria so first
let's talk about cavities and what they
are they are also sometimes called
dental caries but they're basically
damage to the teeth where you're getting
holes in the enamel they can get so bad
that even like the underlying root can
be exposed which can be very painful and
so they can be the result of several
factors excuse me
one is a diet high in acidic foods so if
you are eating a lot of food that has an
acidic nature then that acid can break
down your enamel so this would be like
if you're drinking soda several times a
week if you're having a lot of lemon
juice my mom knew someone once who would
suck on like lemon wedges like with the
lemon wedge in their mouth and just
really stuck on it and like walk around
with it in there and that degraded their
tooth enamel and they got lots and lots
of cavities from that also poor oral
hygiene so this refers to you know
improper brushing not doing it often
enough not spending enough time when you
are brushing your teeth not getting all
of the tooth surfaces forgetting to
floss would be another example of poor
oral hygiene this can also contribute to
cavities and then the third kind of
major factor is acid that is produced by
oral bacteria and this right here is our
major focus today so certain oral
bacteria can ferment remember that's a
metabolic process confirm it
tyranny carbohydrates
and we're talking about carbohydrates
I'm talking about simple sugars things
like soda candy muffins also too refined
carbohydrates things like white bread
bagels muffins that kind of thing but
really any carbohydrate can contribute
to this process that if we're having a
diet high and those refined
carbohydrates it's even more likely so
they these bacteria they live in our
mouths when we eat the sugar they
ferment the sugar and that produces
acids like lac d'oo like what excuse me
like lactic acid and the lactic acid
then degrades the enamel that protective
covering on your teeth and specifically
it does this through a process known as
decalcification so this is where the
lactic acid contributes to leaching the
calcium out of your enamel making it
softer and eventually making it degrade
and wear away altogether and there are
several examples of bacteria that can do
this process lactobacillus acidophilus
and streptococcus mutants are the two
that we care about most often there's
also acted on my Caesar Don to little
kiss and and and many more so there's
various types of bacteria that are
capable of fermenting those sugars that
are in your mouth and producing the
acids that will break down your tooth
enamel and whereas the acid production
is the major cause that contributes to
the breakdown of the enamel it's not the
only type of mechanism possible
sometimes bacteria have even additional
mechanisms that contribute to this
process so for example streptococcus
mutans
the one listed right here it excretes
something called dextran sucrase
and even if you've never heard of it you
should be able to tell me what it is
it ends in eighth whenever we have
something ending in face that generally
meant means that it's an enzyme so
streptococcus mutans excretes this
enzyme that polymerizes sucrose member
sucrose is table sugar it's composed of
glucose and fructose so it polymerizes
sucrose into this kind of job like
matrix of glucan plus fructose in the
dental plaque
so the dental plaque being that biofilm
that forms on your teeth
overnight and also just generally when
you aren't brushing very well so you get
this dental plaque that lots of bacteria
living in the dental plaque and so the
strength dukakis newtons excretes this
enzyme that polymerizes the sucrose
actually takes the table sugar from the
food that you're eating from the cookies
and the candy and the cake and whatever
else and polymerize it into this matrix
where it can live and thrive and then
specifically the fructose that's in that
matrix the streptococcus means hands
will ferment that fructose to lactic
acid you know which is one of the acids
that degrades the tooth enamel and so
what can you do about this if you have
these bacteria living in your mouth does
that mean that you're doomed to having
cavities no you have two major types of
defense you can have good oral hygiene
you can brush several times a day you
can floss you can make sure that you're
getting a new toothbrush as often as
you're supposed to use anti cavity
mouthwashes
depending on what your dentist
recommends and then also following a low
sugar diet you know opting for water
instead of soda or fruit juice at meals
reducing the amount of rough
carbohydrates in your diet that will
help you to be able to prevent cavities
as well as other diseases that are
linked to high carbohydrate diets things
like you know heart disease and diabetes
and that kind of thing as well so
consider how you can carry out these
steps to prevent cavities susceptibility
and you're interested in how someone can
determine their individual cavity
susceptibility based on quantifying the
levels of the of the acid production
that their oral bacteria can carry out
then please check out my video called
Schneider Test auger for determining
cavity susceptibility and thanks for
watching biology professor have a great
day